a war zone rated 53 players average
rating 1817 time handicap as usual
30-minute tournament anybody could enter
no level needed no specific level joined
chess cube and you're already ready to
enter this one as long as you have an
entry fee of twenty cubits here we go
here we go here we go here we go
crusher Corral for sure Karev here we go
let's not get crushed more c5 like in
the c5 okay now it's exchange caro-kann
by transposition right the light square
Bishop out of my eventual central
structure Bishop d6 or e7 okay e7 break
the pin back up and get ready to
challenge the light square Bishop Queen
c2 rook c8 let's play here let's play
here actually why did I play their queen
here I was still thinking the bishop was
on that square I was stupid I was stupid
hmm I captured the Queen I guess and
let's see if they M take that take my
light square bishop more double puns
okay I have a plan and it involves
getting my knight okay let's stop that
night from doing anything against my
Knight to d6
take my bishop okay
what my knight on d6 or my bishop on c7
now actually she found c7 let's come
over here
this is stupid what am i doing what am i
doing okay
take that and now my king has to come
all the way back over here to watch a
pond that's okay though alright no it's
not it's not gonna do that they don't
have any time I don't have any time in
fact I could get to this square right
now
you get to this square here we go and
then I'll come here get that night over
here and guard this get in what they
don't have any time do that now you just
take here and then get that night out of
there no mates how much time is left how
much time is left King over defend that
pond back to tournament that was stupid
that was stupid on my part right there
what I was doing with my king that was
ridiculous I was floundering floundering
okay French or not okay some small pond
center I don't know about this you see
it sometimes with what here we go the
disguise it's in disguise here fishing
pole in disguise you have to set that up
more often a fishing pole kind of
position in disguise killer mates right
around the corner boom boom mates
unavoidable it's an unavoidable f6 for a
flight squared g6 takes it away rookie
or queen h8 mate that's mate back to
tournament quick kill sixes six six five
five five four here we go lat map more
Sicilian Smith more no thank you no
thank you I do not want to deal with
that
oh here we go
might want to get that pond okay take my
night okay
now I'm looking for what okay that's a
NIC that's a free pun that is a free pun
right there both of these squares now I
could play here with tempo expansion in
the center I should have made me
considered f5 instead Bishop shut down
the night needs to find a new home it's
okay if they take I have an open line
for an attack kick the night away first
and then take if the night plays here
okay now back open up the position open
up the LightSquared diagonal in
particular Bishop b7 pawn push maybe
just a sack just to clear the lane I
mean clear the lane pin if Knight D pawn
push maybe as well it's just open it up
I have the bishops uh-oh trouble big
trouble
that's soon-to-be mate very very soon to
be me I was ready to play here that
won't be good that wouldn't be good but
this is close to me very very close to
mate isn't it
fork I get one of the Knights with check
the knight is also pinned let's take
this one that knight is pinned still and
you know it's check I'm on g3 King is
definitely in trouble here definitely in
trouble where is that mate right here is
made back to tournament 1211 6 ok 12s
I'm up there with 12 Lee is also up
there with 12 12 12 11 24 and change a
lot of time a lot of time left here so
now what Mount Everest I have to climb
Mount Everest right here you knew that
one was coming you knew that one was
coming
whenever is Oh the Queen's are off the
Queen's arrived oh oh oh I'm winning
upon this is a Ponce a Klein is this
some gambit no no no no no no no let's
take care more development hit the clean
check get on this same diagonal or yeah
that's a diagonal all right sure it is
sure it is there's Bishop takes here and
then an in-between move where you grab a
pun I want to watch f2 wanna watch f2
watch out for f2 ok Queen trade I'm
alright with that let's watch over these
squares watch over him
there's my bishop gonna be chased away
let's go here let's go here and then go
here watch over this square in case of a
night pivot and then what mmm
let's hit this rook and then play here
just right here is enough
hit the knight chase it to somewhere
else right here right here and then man
look at my bishop look at how stupid my
bishop is c4 Bishop b2 that's the way is
it gonna come to d5 or d4
you might want to get to this target
that pond and then pinpoint it up here
rook h4 if the King went here rook age
for first let's do this how much time I
don't have any time of any time what
have I been doing this whole game I
could have just taken that I could have
just taken that Oh move move move move
how much time
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go no
stalemates no stalemates
no stalemates you know stalemates mate
20 20 20 oh man where did my time go
from that one jeez okay 22 and change
here 22 tikka Rooskies left here we go
Sofia Sophie ah okay each pond launched
it it's being launched the H pond is
being launched okay here we go a quick
attack on g3 quick attack on g3 taking
the bishop with check uh-oh Oh with
check I got the rook and the Queen big
trouble big trouble open up this for my
bishop and queen if the king is gonna be
on a dark square I'm still gonna go
there Bishop to c5 as a killer hang on
Queen g2 let's run home let's run home
actually Queen H why why did I do that
Queen to h4 was good that was stupid I'm
on here light square bishop wants to
play it wants to play one day and here
it comes here we go let's come back here
I could have taken that button all right
all right all right all right all right
all right let's go light square bishop
do something do something do something
quick bishop check or is the Queen gonna
give check let's do this let's do this
clean out queenside castle if the night
plays here it's really not hitting that
point here we go
take here just Castle I could grab there
with check but let's get this in let's
go
check here just open stuff up open stuff
up rook check also I'm on f4 and on the
rook I'm that rook packed a tournament
that are out of time 30 30 25 kappa rot
1 ok lens lens x1 sicilian closed let's
see maybe now let's not go it's just
sitting close let's open it up open it
up and look for f4 f5 in fact us let's
get out of forks first there is that
opportunity for fork f5 uh-oh very
difficult to defend against tonight that
deep in your position Queen to g3 let's
do this actually let's do this and now
try and put my dark square Bishop to use
ooh ok I missed that the knight can't
move let's get that Bishop out of there
and then maybe a pawn push or takes I
think takes is best yeah takes his best
and then I'm gonna do the pin I had also
Bishop h6 available I should just take
him I was dumb I should've just taken
here
ok ooh ooh that's a slick move oh that
one wasn't I think just Knight takes
Knight Knight takes Knight and I'm in
big trouble
okay mate threat mate thread on there
they missed it back to tournament they
got out of the queen pin but I just had
Queen there me okay we're still tied
here myself in that Kappa Rock Kappa
Rock okay so what is that a pond doing I
don't understand that let's build a
center in the meantime if they're gonna
be doing those flank type of moves and
now I have a light square bishop that I
want to put to use
get out of there Knight get out of there
I should have let's go let's go
open it up
take undermine the night undermine that
night give a check undermine this Queen
h4 what am i doing let's take care
check get the Queen that's me that's
close to mate isn't it now I'm getting
the Queen though definitely get in that
clean and then I'm getting what next
getting another Queen getting their
queen and then that okay I could be
giving check here that's me whoa nice 72
whoa he has 72 I 56 still more than half
to go here a lot of time less than 15
has been played oh you've already played
this guy before now you didn't go with
the Queen side Fink at all let's do this
and break down their Center I'm winning
this pond no Bishop takes pawn here
let's hit the Queen first we should take
stairs this is still available and now
I'm gonna go like this and pivot on d6
let's go here watch out for g2 and those
types of things
watch over g2 although my queen isn't
there to watch over g2 anymore they
missed that and f6 is a killer f6 is a
killer in between move I'll play b5 if
pawn takes in fact I'll just do it right
now just do it right now and then take
here and then shut down that light
square bishop or fork okay that's a
that's difficult that's difficult to
deal with f6 brutal
it's got to be brutal right there okay
f7 now f7 is going down
Oh what am i doing oh come on man
no more Mouse lips let's go here what am
i doing you know ah
it just can't be smooth cannon it just
can't be smooth one more Mouse lips more
mouse lips it better not be stalemate
no stalemate no stalemate no stalemate
no stalemate just keep giving check then
you know it won't be stalemate then you
know won't be stalemate
check check here we go
check check and then check me just move
just moved back to tournament 70 to 90
72 that guy's playing a game right now
he already has a lead how can i overtake
him if he keeps winning do I need to get
paired up against them I might need to
do that I might need to do that Sicilian
justice veteran ACOG this is a bit
different no no I don't want to enter
the gambit land here no I want to be the
one throwing the gambits if anything
here we go I need a quick win this is
the way to do it
take that night just take him please
he's free it's a free night okay I'm
gonna take this guy and then this guy
and then this and then get to the dark
squares whoa they're looking for they're
looking to kill me Oh Bishop here Bishop
here oh oh it's a little scary check it
was a little scary
they had Bishop right here that would
have been oh man oh man oh man okay
let's shut that down Bishop takes I
might have to run scared oh okay all
right this isn't gonna be a quick kill
but I'm at least safe with my king right
safe with my king castle what take the
Queen you idiot
oh man take free Queens take free Queens
what are you doing and watch it I better
not look at this that's close to
actually be a mate oh man man
huh boy let's do this geez this is so
bad
what am i doing that's a free Queen
Queen III and what I do I castle yeah
let's just Castle yeah even though you
want to just Castle who needs a free
queen not me I'm not looking to win
quick or anything just move push push
give a check they're down on time just
go here just run away back to tournament
9110 they're up 20 they have ten games
in and they're playing another one and
probably close to winning I need to
fight back with these last 15 minutes
let's go let's go here need to fight
back I should have made me just no I
couldn't okay now I'm getting this F
pawn for free unless g5g v is played
here we go F pawn gone so now a leading
development
recapture like this I've Bishop back if
Queen check Bishop back if Queen check
looking for the G file G file G file the
pawn is pinned as well that's powerless
oh I'm gonna get the Queen the Queen e
I'm actually gonna play oh no this is a
matin - threat man - threat very scary
resignation come on check and then mate
back to tournament that's what I needed
110 ah you're still up twenty twelve and
change how do I take this guy out ah
let's go here I gotta get that guy I'm
going after him I'm going after that guy
here we go push g3 push g3 ready Elisha
I already kicked this guy off right down
let's do it anyhow I don't know what f3
is doing what is f3 doing
I'm not sure okay let's watch over we
want to get to the dark squares we are
in love with the dark squares here right
now and what I mean by that is be five
Bishop e6 ninety seven Knights e5 in
fact let's get the darker bishops off
the board first and then get my Knight
to f4 dark square bishop skit them off
the board exchange those dark square
bishop and your opponent's position
crumbles how can we make that happen
here we go we're gonna have pawn push
I'll counter with d5 and then there's
Forks fork land for Clan Knight h5
that's why I did this pawn push and also
to mess up their structure their way
down on time 21 20 19 rook b8 hitting b2
is a way to go
they must be logged off or something
okay this is um maybe it's fairly quick
win Howard maybe is that kind just maybe
gonna slip up once that'd be nice
somebody take that guy out
maybe I'll get paired up with them and
then it'll be on my shoulders come on
their clock reads zero don't tell me
that my clock is really moving no it's
not I have to wait another five seconds
just so they could check the server's
just to make sure I've gotta make sure
okay they made sure just making sure
oh now there's two guys up there what's
happening rack guitar I gotta play
against rack guitar
gambits land I have to overtake two guys
how much time is left 10 and change 10
and change
gambits gambit land pushing night I'm
setting it up I'm setting it up Bishop
d3 move knight move knight one day you
want to move come on come on here we go
here we go I'm watching it it's getting
ready to be kicked off oh do I have it
check no I don't have it
mmm yeah I do have it a sort of too
weird very variation of it oh it's a
weird variation it doesn't lead to mate
but I'm close to it I'm close to
Maitland here we go Queen h5 queen h5 o
right here making one - making one or
two - or one oh I just want to take the
knight I just want to take the knight
man why'd they have to run away take
Jack
check check check check check and then
right here get my rook to h7 don't run
away King I'm on the night I'm on the
night you want to resign you definitely
want to resign yes they wanted to reach
nothing 190 how do you catch 190 190 137
ah that guy is getting it's he's just
extending his lead how do you overtake
that guy I don't understand
come on quick resigner x' where are the
quick resigner x' of the tournament
there's no quick resigner x' take on
that floor yes
hot push okay launch the Jeep on launch
them launch that Jeep on and then take
the e pond I'm on the bishop oh oh there
must be scared let's develop let's
develop f3 I want that night in
move I want that guy to move move
actually Knight right here and then I
get to f3 by force by force f3 hit the
Queen first I want Forks okay is this
close to a fork is the Queen dead is the
Queen close to dead pawn push and I
could deal with a knight f6 move I could
deal with the knight f6 move oh I
thought I could play here and I can't
cuz the night right there would be
killer
you'd be a killer it would definitely be
a killer I have to play here that's kind
of sad but I got this Knight and then
there's Queen here that's scary
okay oh oh I'm missing something here
man oh I should just take in the night
what am i doing develop okay Bishop to
hear next wow talk about a a bunch of
minor pieces right here in the center my
Kings in trouble
oh oh I got this I got this and I'm
defending my knight they don't have any
time they're down on time just throw in
a check and burn their time don't let my
clock tick don't let my clock tick no
more taking of my clock back determine
172 10 6 and change 6 and change let's
go tani tani 97 quick resigned quick
resign oh come on come on click Mike
Mike my friend
I got a pin and stuff and hit my queen
this isn't gonna lead to anything quick
is it my piece is out a 5 yes they
resigned back to tournament 210 196 and
change 6 a change Oh sneak it up there
Maryellen 16 pair me up come on I cannot
afford for this did not prepare me up
right away let's go let's go let's go
let's go come
double the points and resign double the
points are they just gonna let the clock
tick and I could win in 55 seconds from
now are they gonna end up checking the
server bla bla bla
how much time five and change five and
change if I could win this one and then
two more I have to do some home cooking
no let me pre move that and let me track
that guy down I didn't need oh he's got
230 already come on who's playing cap
who's playing the cap guy wears cap
where does cap I can't even find them is
my game going
nope nothing in that my name 20 seconds
and change on that game cap where are
you cap
trying to do some homework on you see
what you're playing there we go it is
the leader he is 250 now come on white
oh this guy might beat him he has he's
at 2,500 oh oh let's go back to my game
there might be hope he might go
backwards he's playing against a 2500 oh
he has to play against a big fish I've
got 200 liters what do we got 250 oh I
only have 200 and he has 250 this guy
again
I have pet I've been paired up with this
guy quite a bit already
Smith Mona maybe win the Queen I might
be able to win the Queen Oh f7 I should
target f7 right now right now resign I'm
on the rook I got the Queen let's go
resign check castle grab on f4 grab on
f4 push this pawn chase the night away
get to f7 guard I get to this point
right here that's another check oh come
on I got everything here check I got the
bishop I'm just gonna take it and then I
got the rope I got everything right
check queen we're get the night or the
rook check here look up and over mate
look up and over oh now it's mate can't
be defended just move just move just
move just move just move anything just
move don't let your clock tick just move
no I can't afford a clock tick err no no
clock tick or is here how much time free
and change I need every second let's go
this is kill me back to turn into 20
that guy didn't lose he want he must
have won that last game he's got 217 app
3 nap 3 and I'm still having to win all
these games it's still having to win all
these games and I'm not even close to
catching that guy how is this happening
here we go I'm setting it up I'm
unleashing the Beast here we go at least
the beast right here Knight g4 chase a
knight look for me
oh it's tricky tricky tricky tricky grab
a bishop Queen here even trickier even
trickier I come back oh I'm on this
square it's very scary should be very
scared got a capture with the knight
check come back here for me take care oh
oh oh
move Knight ah ok anything anything
the knight still can't be taken imagine
that imagine that
oh there's Knight checks though there's
tricky checks oh man oh man I'm in
trouble
I got a defend like this that's bad
that's really bad Oh
oh that still can't be taken look at
this after all that after all that let's
defend this pawn let's come over here
and try and win a rook and pawn endgame
here we go
hang on I like that guy too much and
he's falling he's following run King run
King defend rook recapture how much time
hit the Jeep on run King keep my rook my
rook needs to be around no no traits for
you no trades throwing some checks time
burner more time burners I need their
time burning me time burner time burner
no no no no no no no no no
they're never gonna suspect that Oh
inspector I got it they didn't take my
pawn oh my goodness how do you catch
some aren't people throwing games to
that guy oh he's got 310 that is
ridiculous
what oh my heart skipped a beat I
thought that that was me that would have
been pretty sad that would have been
pretty sad right there let's chop chop
it up chop it up hit the bishop defend
this get castled actually let's do this
first what are they doing that Queen is
going nuts the queen is going nuts I'm
gonna Castle kingside
how much time is left 11 seconds I got
to win in 11 seconds come on 11 seconds
11 seconds to mate what do we got what
do we got three two one I'm definitely
not getting first resign quick me
I know it's second and Oh second place
confetti oh the first place confetti is
so much more fun I tell you it is so
much more fun that second place confetti
oh wow are you kidding me 23 games it's
only a third
minute tournament good games